Despite the stereotypically female following,...
...yoga has been used by professional athletes for years...
...to increase flexibility, improve balance and focus the mind.
No athlete wants to be an inflexible mess,...
...but it can be hard for men to imagine themselves in complicated poses.
So, here are my favorite yoga moves for the physically active man.
Downward-facing dog strengthens the arms, legs and core...
...while stretching your shoulders, hamstrings and calves.
Make sure that your weight is evenly distributed between your legs and your arms...
...to get the full effect of the move.
If you can do only one pose a day, start with downward dog.
The bridge is easy for beginners and stretches the chest, neck, spine and hips.
Tight chest muscles can limit lung capacity, and over time,...
...this pose can improve performance in all physical activities...
...and help relieve symptoms of upper respiratory issues.
The boat is ideal for strengthening your core and back muscles...
...as well as promoting healthy thyroid and prostate gland function.
While beginners may need to use a hand on the floor,...
...your balance will improve before you know it.